well they say you need to end strong so
good on you Gotham Gotham season for
season finale no man's land and thank
you this I was really nervous for this
episode especially considering that I
haven't especially loved the last couple
of episodes this was the kind of nuts
that I loved this show for this was
exactly what I wanted out of a season
finale for this show even though he did
exactly what I thought they were gonna
do I called it the Blues bombs we're
still gonna be used to turn Gotham into
an island so we can do no-man's land
I called it I knew exactly where the
main thrust of this episode was going
and I still love it I love what is being
set up for no man's land I love that
they're setting up all the villains just
carving out turf and and and creating
their own little territories Mr Freeze
and Firefly and Barbara did and and her
our lady screaming I'm basically of no
man zone oh my god oh okay okay
MVP of this episode for me Lee uh-huh
I love how they have wrapped up I mean
for the time being I'm sure they'll
they'll be back but and furred stinky
within the confines in this episode how
they have wrapped up the Ed and Lee
thing and specifically with her because
in this episode she tells not one but
two men that they don't get to define
her they don't get to dictate to her she
does not have to condone to what they
want her to be she has so much agency in
this episode and she takes it she's got
a debt literally a death grip on it so I
love that in
itself how much she just plants her her
flag in the sand and says no I'm doing
this for me this is not something you
get to claim ownership of and I love
that and then I love the absurdity of
two people who just stabbed each other
and are dieing stopping to kiss each
other that is the kind of stuff I love
this show for cuz it's stupid but it's
perfect it's the exact kind of crazy
campy I can't believe they just did that
but I'm so happy they did moment ditto
with penguin killing butch when he
pulled that trigger I was like boy how
are they gonna justify that and then he
said do you think I forgot that you
killed my mother am i oh that's perfect
justify I'm doing this cuz he did care
about her that much is this twisted and
now it means that the last couple
episodes of stuff that he's been doing
was not him floundering trying to find
whatever advantage good it was his
culmination his completion of the
execution of this revenge scheme against
Tabitha yes that's perfect Jeremiah's
working for me better and here are
honestly largely just do to him the grid
know when the when the when the bridges
are blowing up I think maybe the where
Jeremiah's working for me more because
he's not he's not full-blown yet he's
still kind of cooking as the Joker
I'm liking but he's not the focus of an
episode so like here he gets you know a
scene with Bruce that works well it gets
a scene with Ra's al Ghul we get to see
his excitement at the bridges being
blown up and that's kind of it
so he just gets to shine these moments
he and as a character he doesn't have to
carry the whole episode and I feel like
this is gonna endear this sort of use of
him is going to endear him to me
way better than putting in front and
center like they did for the last couple
of episodes where he wasn't quite
working for me
Ra's al Ghul dead again please let him
stay dead
and I feel like they they finished what
they were trying to do with him I kind
of expected he was gonna come back after
they killed him the first time a because
coming back from the dead is kind of
Ra's al Ghul's old thing but beyond that
it also felt like they hadn't finished
whatever it was they were gonna the the
reason for him to being for being there
now it feels like they have and I like
how that has set
Bruce onto his path I love Bruce making
the decision you know I I have to stay I
have to fight for this city I'm choosing
to do this I know I don't have a
responsibility but I'm choosing to make
it my responsibility I love that I'm
really curious as to what they're gonna
do with Selena it's like they are like
gonna make her the next or Oh cuz they
seem to have borrowed a bit of The
Killing Joke with the whole spine injury
and theoretically not being able to walk
up to that so I don't know how that's
gonna pan out but I'm curious and yeah
just yes so much yes to all this and
Barbara gets that I have a hand in
killing Roz and that works really well
that made me happy I'm just Hugo Strange
you're back in town always makes me
happy like there oh I love this finale
this is great this is awesome and it
also sets up stuff that I'm gonna be so
excited for for the last season of
Gotham I think no man's land is honestly
the perfect story to go out on for
Gotham that the city is broken it's
isolated things are gonna be worse than
they have ever been
and that is what will finally push Bruce
to the level that he decides you know
what
putting on a bad
outfitting jumping on people from roofs
rooftops that's the way to fix what's
going on in this town it's kind of
escalate to the level where that
response suddenly becomes reasonable oh
it's gonna be a long summer waiting for
this show to come back I'm so excited
for more this made me so happy
and it was such a relief after being
iffy on the last couple of episodes so
Gotham season 4 finale what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop them down in the comments let's
talk about it you can follow me on
Twitter I do a podcast with my partner
called punch like a girl you can support
me on patreon links for all that stuff
and more is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]